today we're constantly bombarded with
information that's designed to please
the eye
and to deliver maximum often visual
impact
within a short amount of time
there's million dollar efforts from
large corporations
to grab our attention every way and to
keep it there
when we become immersed into this
colorful information
our other haptic senses of experiencing
the world becomes
desensitized this doesn't only have an
impact on our perception and our
psychology
but it actually also has an indirect
impact on our built environment
with the development of digital
publications and apps like instagram
and pinterest more than ever before we
consume
architecture through the screen rather
than in person
our experience of architecture has been
condensed
into the money shot instead of
physically experiencing the space
this has led to issues of experiential
impoverishment the elements of
architecture are not
visual units or gestalt they're
encounters
confrontations that interact with memory
uh what so what he's trying to say is
that
our experience of architecture can't be
condensed into
visuals and images but what does memory
have to do with all this
in order to understand this we need to
understand this very basic concept in
architecture
the difference between space and place
if two different authors use the word
red
hard or disappeared no one doubts that
they mean approximately
the same thing but in the case of words
such as place
or space whose relationship with
psychological experience is
less direct there exists a far-reaching
uncertainty of interpretations the idea
of space
and place are definitely connected but a
place
compared to a space is all about how we
interact with it in their research paper
neuroscience and architecture
esther sternberg and matthew wilson
found that the same part of the brain is
activated
when navigating around the space and
when
recalling autobiographical events and
this part of the brain
is called hippocampus our memory of
events
may depend upon a strong sense of place
and by extension our sense of place may
be influenced by the integrity of
memories formed there
so when we say haptic sense this is
exactly the thing that's activated by
these
place neurons which respond to a
huge amount of different stimuli
including sight
sound smell and a strong sense of
orientation
within the environment in an interview
with the new york times
peter zomthor explained his process
when i start my first idea of a building
is
the material i believe architecture is
about that
it's not about paper it's not about
forms it's about
space and materials so i visited my very
first peter zomtor building
in 2016 on a trip to europe with my
classmates
and i'd seen so many of his buildings in
photographs and in books
but never in real person and i realized
that none of the photos really did it
justice
because his buildings are really about
the sensory experience
our bus dropped us off at the bottom of
a valley
in a small swiss farming village called
and when we got off the bus we could
literally hear
the silence
from afar the curvature of the walls
almost makes the surfaces
look smooth but up close you see the
depth and color and texture
that kind of speaks to its age
and how many years this church has been
sitting in the elements
the threshold comes out at an angle from
the church
and it's an extension interrupting the
perfect flow of the cylinder
the steps are made of concrete so it's
distinct from the rest of the building
the door itself is clad in vertical
strips of wood and
it's enclosed with a threshold and you
almost get sucked into this intense
verticality the door handle is of course
the last thing you touch from the
outside world and it's your first
encounter with the
inside world
and when you walk in you just walk into
a space that's
filled with warmth and light it's a very
simple interior space just one volume
and a ring of vertical columns with
beams and benches by offsetting the
walls from the columns and the floor
and continuing the columns all the way
to the base
we get a sense of levitating in space
there's no windows just glass panels at
the top
which brings in a flood of light without
distracting us with views of these
beautiful mountains
in one of the most beautiful locations
in the world
my memory of this place is so strong
but strangely enough it's not the views
of the mountains or over the village
but the sound of silence of the gravel
path
of the trickling water the light
and the warm touch of wood
you